[Music]
with nearly 25 years of experience in
more than 550 restaurant locations
across the country
todd graves of raising keynes wanted to
pay his success forward
that's right in a new show called
restaurant recovery he gets to do
just that with a little help from some
famous friends
because of the covet 19 pandemic
restaurant owners are struggling like
never before
how dire is this
i'm here to pay it forward that's why
i'm here today we're here at the
historic crown candy
with the help of some famous friends
it's a pleasure to meet you ladies
it's a family-owned business and it's
the type of thing that we're supposed to
support
i think you just fit
to transform and prepare their
restaurants for a new normal i'm going
to need those keys
in just 48 hours with some help with
some really famous friends
joining us now founder and ceo of
raising keynes todd graves along with
one
of those very famous friends you just
saw in that clip actor rob schneider
awesome to see you both really cool to
have you i got to say todd i'll start
with you
i mean lawrence jones has been singing
the praises of your restaurant raising
canes so you got a big fan of that cane
sauce
my favorite i love it i love it i love
my caniacs out there
there we go tell us about tell us about
what you're doing for small business
todd this is really cool
yeah well you know during the pandemic
my sales and raising kings actually went
up because we have the drive through but
that didn't really feel so good because
we were taking it from these independent
family restaurants
that didn't have a drive-through so i
thought how can we help i've done some
tv before i understand the power of it
and so
hired a production team and created
restaurant recovery wow
todd uh i'm from texas
i was just there to eat i came in
obviously
and then todd was there todd really
cares about
uh people you know and uh he cares about
food most but then people second
and uh these people were struggling in
their restaurant
and they're i mean the the the stuff
that they got there from their culture
in pakistan
and it's been this wonderful beautiful
food they cook this nan
and they have a special place and uh you
just
they've got their heart and soul for 25
years into this place
and to see them struggling and taking
money out of their pocket
every week and job is telling me about
these lovely people and
to give them a chance just to to get
back to just breaking even and to make
some money
it just brought tears to their eyes
because their hopes and dreams and the
kid put his life aside help his mom out
the restaurant i mean
you can't you cannot help but be
emotionally involved with these people
in there
and todd really was able to make a
difference for each of these
restaurants and it was i was amazed it
was great to be part of it it's pretty
amazing and we actually have a clip from
the discovery plus series that series
again
restaurant recovery let's take a look
there he is my friend rob snyder
nice to see you todd's a buddy of mine
and uh oh my god oh my god i can't
this family has been struggling since
the pandemic started i'm sorry we're
just
and rob's the perfect guy to help lift
their spirits incredible right
up seeing rob snyder he's such a
cultural icon
so we lost our we believe like the one
was doing like this
todd knows this business more than
anybody and uh he's here to help and i'm
here to eat
todd i gotta ask you because you know
back in texas we have these
everywhere you guys pride yourself on
customer
service as well in serving the people
are you teaching the folks
these businesses how to step up their
game as well
yeah well you don't i really didn't have
to fix anything these were great
restaurant owners but they couldn't have
prepared for a pandemic
right and so just just think about this
episode that rob helped out
you know overnight this tempe restaurant
lost all their customer base from the
university because it just shut down
classes are canceled then it went
virtual so overnight they go down to not
not much now their food forest food was
amazing
so and rob loved it but he gave me a
good point he said hey you need to get
this food out to phoenix greater phoenix
area has what five million people that
spurred getting a
delivery vehicle right and then they
also had a storage area
that they weren't using for anything but
they wanted to launch this concept
called chai corner right some chai and
some coffee house
and which was a great idea especially by
campus um but i took that idea and
really launched their concept right
so those two things not only got them
through the pandemic but now that we're
coming out
the other side of it they're doing
better than they ever have wow
something else part of that and see them
uh because they were at their bottom
when todd came in i mean literally like
uh their customers
not only were they not having any
customers but the customers that come in
there was only a limited amount so it
was all food to go
and uh to see that turn around which was
really heartwarming and rob are they
are they do you sense that they're you
know hopeful that that this
that they're coming out of it and they
can now compete with the
the raising canes of the world oh yeah
absolutely i mean they have their niche
and they were doing well
but like um the struggle was going on
for so long
and the they were literally putting
their life savings into this and also
the kids were stopping their lives
to you know to keep this this going and
it was just kept there was losing money
every month every month and hanging in
there
and so todd was able to go in there and
make some adjustments and get their food
out to like they said to to other people
in other areas
through this uh you know food
transportation vehicle
and then it just ended up having the
place next door so it was able to
i'm telling you to see people's dreams
and and see them to have
hope again and to see them turn around
it's something else i mean
you don't get the chance to really be a
part of that or see that and like i was
just there to eat the nan
and the other formula stuff they had and
chicken corn and stuff
and it's beautiful food but the stories
of the people and how she brought that
it's her mother's recipe and her
grandma's recipe
it really it makes you really appreciate
food and appreciate culture
beautiful michigan it's a beautiful
american uh story unfortunately
gentlemen we got a scoop but
todd i got to ask you before we leave
when is new york city going to get a
raisin cane
good question i'm working on it real
estate's a little bit difficult
i'll be calling you to partner up i'll
be calling you we'll
maybe we can get something done together
i'm going to bring in a bag of it for
you though
support small business uh family owned
let's uh would support them let's change
do fine support that small restaurant
small business go do it you can do it
thank you so much that's what we needed
that's what we was missing this segment
you can do it thank you both for being
here so inspiring
so much fun we're going fishing guys
and restaurant recovery is streaming now
on discovery plus you can watch rob's
episode on may
13th todd graves rob schneider amazing
we can't wait to watch